UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE MAKING
FURTHER GAINS IN THE SOUTH
PUSHING TOWARDS THE CUPIED --
THAT IS JUST DAYS AFTER THE
UKRAINE PUSHED THROUGH THE CITY
OF LYMAN.
THIS COMES JUST AFTER
CONSIDERING HOW TO RESPOND TO
AN INVASION FROM THE RUSSIANS
INCLUDING THEIR USE OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THREE SIKH KARI JOINS ME.
NOW GOOD TO.
SEE >> IT'S A PLEASURE.
>> SO RUSSIA IS TRYING TO MAKE
THE TERRITORIAL CLAIM THAT THEY
ARE FACING THESE SETBACKS.
AS I RELEASE, VIDEO AS YOU CAN
SEE THE UKRAINIAN TROOPS ARE
DRIVING THROUGH THE RETRAINED
LINE.
HOW DOES THE PUTIN EFFORT PLAY
OUT ON THE BATTLEFIELD?
>> IT IS LOOKING A BIT OF A
DISASTER RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
LIMON IS STRATEGICALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT.
IT IS A KEY LOGISTICAL HUB.
SO THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE GOT
IT MAKES IT MUCH EASIER FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO KEEP MOVING EAST.
HER SON IS WHERE THE HEART OF
THE BATTLE.
IS IF THEY WIN IN HER, SON AND
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD EVERY
HOUR.
THEY'VE GAINED 20 OR 30 MILES.
WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A SMALL
AMOUNT, BUT IT IS ACTUALLY A
LOT.
IT TAKES A LOT TO MOVE 2030
MILES.
HER SON IS THE HEART OF THE
BATTLE.
IF THEY START MOVING THROUGH
THE RUSSIAN POSITION SOUTH, IT
MEANS UKRAINE WILL LIVE.
IT WILL BE A VIABLE COUNTRY NO
MATTER WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THIS.
BECAUSE YOU CAN GET BACK THE
COAST.
THEY IT BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE FOR
THE RUSSIANS TO TAKE ODESSA OR
BECOMES VERY VERY DIFFICULT.
SO, IT IS ALMOST LIKE A PENCIL
MOVEMENT.
THIS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
THIS IS PROBABLY, WE ARE
WITNESSING THE TURNING POINT OF
THE WAR.
IF THE HER SON ADVANCES
CONTINUE.
BECAUSE IF THE UKRAINIANS CAN
KEEP MOVING, THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY DRIVING THE
RUSSIANS OUT OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT GAINS THEY HAVE MADE
IN 2022.
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF STUFF
THEY DID IN 2014 AND 15 WHICH
IS A SEPARATE ISSUE.
BUT OF THE STUFF THAT THEY TOOK
THIS YEAR, HER SON, THIS AREA
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT IN THE
SOUTH.
IT IS WHAT BLOCKED ACCESS TO
THE SEA, IT IS WHY THE UKRAINE
CAN EXPORT THEIR GRAIN, EXPORT
FOOD.
SO, IF THEY ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO DO THIS IT IS HUGE.
AND AS YOU SAID, PUTIN SAYS HE
IS THE NEXT TERRITORY, BUT IT
SPOKESMAN SAYS WE DON'T EXACTLY
HOW MUCH WE HAVE AND WE HAD OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PUPPET
RULERS OF THOSE REGIONS.
BUT ONE OF THOSE PUPPET RULER
SEEMS TO HAVE JUST BEEN
ASSASSINATED.
SO THEY WILL HAVE TO FIND
SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> I THINK YOU WILL GET THIS
QUESTION.
SO THEN, WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
PUTIN?
WHERE IS HE?
BECAUSE IF HE DOESN'T HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS GOING
ON AND HE IS THE GUY AT THE TOP
OF THE PUPPET MASTER.
DOES HE HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT IS GOING ON >> YOU HAVE
TO IMAGINE WHAT IS HAPPENED
HERE IS HIGHLY CENTRALIZED BY
--
.
AND THOSE HIGHLY DICTATORIAL
POWER STRUCTURES, BAD NEWS DOES
NOT GO UP.
WHO IS THE PERSON WHO WANTS TO
GO TO PUTIN AND SAY, YOU ARE
IDEA TO INVADE KYIV WAS A BAD
IDEA.
YOUR IDEA TO DO THIS, THESE ARE
ALL BAD IDEAS.
SO THAT IS NOT WHICH HE IS
HEARING.
HE IS HEARING PROBABLY THE MOST
SUGAR COATED VERSION OF ALL.
BUT, AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
THING ABOUT WAR IS IF YOU ARE
LOSING TERRITORY IT IS VERY
HARD TO SUGARCOAT.
THAT >> SO TO ADD TO THE NEXT
QUESTION, HE'S BEEN ADDING UP
THIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
SABER-RATTLING.
AND SO SOURCES BRIEFED ON MOST
RECENT INTELLIGENCE, SAYING
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DEVELOPING
CONTINGENCY PLANS.
THE U.S..
THE U.S. IS TAKING THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
OH THE U.S. HAS TO TAKE IT
RUSSIA HAS 2000 TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
PUTIN HAS TWICE NOW SAID HE
WILL DEFEND THIS LAND BY EVERY
MEANS POSSIBLE.
AND SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS TAKING IT VERY SERIOUSLY,
AND I'M SURE THEY ARE
DEVELOPING SPECIFIC RESPONSES.
NOW, I WILL TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THE SPECIFIC THING.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
THINK, OH, THIS IS SOME KIND OF
--
SORT OF LEAKING WHAT THE BIDEN
MINISTRATION IS GOING TO DO.
BUT MY SENSE, BASED ON PREVIOUS
DISCUSSIONS WITH SENIOR
OFFICIALS ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN
THESE KINDS OF SITUATIONS IS
THAT IT IS MOSTLY THE UNITED
STATES WOULD NOT RESPOND TO A
TACTICAL NUCLEAR STRIKE BY THE
RUSSIANS WITH A NUCLEAR STRIKE
OF ITS OWN.
IT WOULD NOT --
THEY MAY BEHAVE RESPONSIBLY, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO BEHAVE
IRRESPONSIBLY.
>> WHAT THEY WOULD DO WOULD BE
MASSIVE CONVENTIONAL RESPONSE.
THE U.S. COULD JUST BE ONE
EXAMPLE.
IT CAN DO IN HER BOMBARDMENT
CAMPAIGN THAT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
DESTROY EVERY RUSSIAN MILITARY
POSITION AND UKRAINE.
EFFECTIVELY ENDING THE WAR.
UKRAINIAN TROOPS WOULD THEN
WALK INTO THOSE POSITIONS.
>> SO, IF IT DECIDED THAT IT
WAS SERIOUS ENOUGH THAN THE
U.S. HAS THE CAPACITY DON'T
THINK THE RUSSIANS WILL BE ABLE
TO STOP IT.
THE U.S. HAS MUCH MUCH BETTER
CAPACITY.
BUT THEY WOULDN'T USE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
>> LISTEN, THIS IS A FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR WHEN HE SAID WHAT HE
WAS --
WE TALKED ABOUT, LET'S HEAR IT.
>> JUST TO GIVE YOU A
HYPOTHETICAL.
WE WOULD RESPOND BY LEADING A
NATO, A COLLECTIVE EFFORT, THAT
WILL TAKE OUT EVERY RUSSIAN
CONVENTIONAL FORCE THAT WE
COULD SEE AND IDENTIFY.
ON THE BATTLEFIELD, AND
UKRAINE.
AND ALSO IN CRIMEA, AND EVERY
SHIP ON THE BLACK SEA.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> I THINK THIS WILL BE A
BRUTAL PLAN, AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
50,000 RUSSIAN TROOPS.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE RUSSIANS,
AND LAST WEEK ON MY PROGRAM,
LLOYD AUSTIN THIS CENTER OF
DEFENSE INDICATED THAT HE HAD
COMMUNICATED TO HIS RUSSIAN
COUNTERPART.
THE NATURE OF THE AMERICAN
RESPONSE.
PROBABLY OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
SPECIFIC SOLUTION.
I THINK THE RUSSIANS --
I OWN SENSES, WE'VE ALL GOTTEN
PUTIN WRONG, BUT AUSTIN SAID
THIS.
HE'S GOING TO TRY THIS
MOBILIZATION FIRST.
IT'S BEEN A VERY POLITICALLY
PAINFUL THING.
IT'S BEEN VERY UNPOPULAR IN
RUSSIA.
REMEMBER, NONE OF THEM ARE OUT
THERE.
SO FIRST HE'S GOING TO TRY
THAT.
AND THE UKRAINIANS ARE --
BECAUSE RUSSIANS ARE GONNA TRY
AND TAKE BACK THE ROUNDER
LOSING.
SO THE UKRAINIANS HAVE TO KEEP
PUSHING FORWARD.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGE.
WHICH MEANS WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONQUERING ON --
THE CONQUERING ARMY HAS TO KEEP
LOTS OF TROOPS IN ALL THE
CITIES AND IT TAKES HOLD IN THE
CITIES AGAINST DOUBLE THE
PEOPLE.
WHEN THE LIBERATING ARMY COMES,
IT DOESN'T NEED TO DO AS MUCH
OF THAT.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE SECURING
THE CITY FOR THEM.
WE KNOW IN WORLD WAR II, WHEN
PARTIES WERE TAKING CITIES
THERE, THESE HUGE NUMBERS OF
TROOPS.
BUT THE ALLIES DIDN'T.
>> WITH HISTORY HAVE THE NUMBER?
A >> IT DOES.
IT WAS A BIG COUNTRY, HUNDRED
50 MILLION PEOPLE, THEY HAVE
300,000 CALLED UP NOW.
THEY CAN CALL UP ANOTHER.
>> OR IF THEY'RE MORE ORGANIZED?
>> THE WHOLE THING WE --
GAIN CONFIDENCE, PART OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN HERE IS, YOU KNOW,
RUSSIA AS A MILITARY POWER HAS
ITS REPUTATION HAS SUFFERED A
DEVASTATING BLOW.
REMEMBER WAS RUSSIA'S CLAIM TO
POWER?
OIL, AND GUNS?
WELL WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THAT
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY I TELL MY
FRIENDS IN INDIA.
INDIAN MILITARY HAS FOUGHT FOR
NOT DECADES OF ITS ADVANCEMENT
OR COMMENT FOR THE RUSSIANS.
ARE YOU WATCHING HOW THIS STUFF
IS PERFORMING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD?
I REALLY WANTED TO THIS?
I PREDICT IN THE NEXT --
THE MILITARY WILL START BY A
LOT OF AMERICAN AND FRENCH AND
BRITISH STUFF.
I TRIED TO PHASE OUT OF THE
RUSSIAN STUFF.
THIS IS BEEN A DEVASTATING BLOW
TO THE RUSSIANS.
THEIR MILITARY EQUIPMENT
DOESN'T FUNCTION, THEIR MENTAL
WANT TO FIGHT, THEIR SOLDIERS
THAT WANT TO FIGHT.
IT IS A DISASTER, BUT THAT IS
WHY YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
NUCLEAR WEAPON IS SO RELEVANT.
BECAUSE PUTIN IS NOT GOING TO
SIT STILL.
HE'S GOING TO FIGHT BACK.
MY GUESS IS, WE WILL FIRST TRY
TO TAKE OUT UKRAINE'S ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND BOMB THE POWER PLANTS.
BUT THOSE CITIES --
SO THIS MAY BE A VERY TOUGH
PERIOD FOR THOSE UKRAINIAN
TOWNS AND CITIES.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE WITHOUT
HEAT, POTENTIALLY WITHOUT LIGHT,
BUT THEY WILL FIGHT.
IT IS THEIR COUNTRY.
>> I WAS A PLEASURE.
MAKE US ALL SMARTER.
THANK YOU FAREED, IT'S A
PLEASURE.